japan's cherry blossoms are
a national favorite historically
blooming at the start of spring
a perfect way to begin a new school year
crowds blocked to tokyo parks in the
first half of april to watch them grow
after a state of emergency under the
pandemic was lifted in the capital and
neighboring prefectures
last year i couldn't come here due to
the state of emergency
this year i wanted to come again so here
i am i've been job hunting online while
attending classes online
i've stayed inside my house really long
it has been such a long time since last
time i went out with my friend
watching cherry blossoms together with
my friend is so refreshing
the problem is it's too early for this
to happen and most blossoms will be gone
before classes begin
when i was a high school student i think
cherry blossoms were still blooming
around the entrance ceremony season in
april
official records only go back 70 years
so researchers at osaka prefecture
university are searching for more data
pouring through centuries of diaries and
letters written by emperors aristocrats
governors and monks in kyoto further
south
the data they collected indicates a
startling trend
it's the earliest that cherry blossoms
have bloomed in 1200 years
experts say it's an indicator of climate
change and urbanization
and they're concerned the early bloom
could jeopardize the future growth
of one of japan's national treasures
the tree becomes weaker when it can't
hibernate well or can't come out of
hibernation
and we call this a life cycle if it
can't come out of hibernation
it won't be able to develop further and
will have problems growing
scientists say like a canary in a coal
mine the early arrival of cherry
blossoms could signal
something's not right and at this rate
they'll become more vulnerable to spring
freezes
and changes in pollination cycles andrew
chappelle
al jazeera